I actually think it's a vast overreach
by the United States government I think
the government has the ability to know
far too much about its citizens and
people should be really upset about that
I really don't think that there is a
breadcrumb trail that you can follow
where if a government knows more about
you you are actually safer as a people I
think there is a breadcrumb trail where
you can follow that the more the
government knows about you probably the
less secure that you are
I don't have any wisdom but I certainly
will tell people what I think regardless
of what they may think about it and how
it lands with them and if you don't like
the answer don't ask me the [__]
question
good stuff Andy's done ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the show
thank you for having me Prime Time
ratings last night CNN 569
000 Fox News 1.73 million okay MSNBC
1.86 million the first episode of Tucker
Carlson on Twitter 82 million in 20
hours so far
so basically an adx increase over what
would be considered traditional
mainstream media yeah of 40 30X over all
three together yeah
well
um
where do you get your news from Mostly
the internet how do you select your
source and how do you bounce you know
we're in an interesting time a time
where I think people have more access to
information than in the history of
humankind and it seems like every day
where through that envelope or threshold
even more
I have seen it in myself I've seen it
other people I'm sure you have too
the pros of the internet is you can find
anything you want to the cons of the
internet is you can find anything that
you want to if you go there pre-cocked
or with some type of confirmation bias
let me just tell anybody what they're
going to find on the internet exactly
what they're looking for
and you can get lost in fake news
literally like satire sites that
sometimes are so ridiculously good
they're hard to tell that they're satire
[__] totally here for it
um you'll come on to traditional media
Outlets like in the Fox News the CNN and
if I'm sorry at this day and age if
people don't realize that everybody and
that message is bought and paid for I
don't know how to help you because it's
right there in your face you'd have to
be blind to not see it and I don't have
a problem with people getting news from
either one of those sources let's just
recognize there's a slant on it and a
bias and also they're in the business of
selling ads just like TV
so it leads you at this place
where do you get information do you go
on the sub stack do you go on to Twitter
do you go on to traditional media
Outlets how much do you have to bounce
it against the other side to determine
that the information that you're getting
is actually legitimate or real did you
see the debate between Malcolm Gladwell
and Douglas Murray a couple of months
ago no you know Malcolm and Douglas as
well yeah and uh it was a discussion
around mainstream media basically needs
it's not something that you should be
able to trust and there were some really
interesting arguments from both sides
that there are constrictions and
guidelines around what you can and can't
do with traditional media that are
unrestricted when it comes to the more
New Media but that also brings with it
degrees of freedom that people can take
advantage of you have a really really
interesting discussion and I think the
sort of terminally online World sees New
Media as this Bastion of free speech
which gets itself closer to the truth
because it's no longer encumbered by any
of the rules and procedures and the
bought and paid for and so on
but I think if everybody took a really
close look at it the incentives are
different but they're still not exactly
pure free speech and Truth are not
always synonymous and I think people
have to be really cautious with that I
don't have a great answer for myself as
to where you even bounce
ideas or resources
especially in a world where
like I've just recently started playing
around with chat GPT holy [__] or Image
Creators holy [__] and these are in the
in like what will be viewed in the very
near future as their infancy if they're
that good right now
and it can really fool intelligent
people
I feel like
Skynet is just around the corner
we are
mere inches away from just getting butt
[__] by robots that's what it's going
to look like
dude I I have a I have a friend who
sells silk pillowcases and bamboo sheets
on Amazon
and he has been Amazon funneling and
building his business up and so on and
so forth it's very effortful to do and
he got chat GPT to write his sales page
for him and then he used mid-journey to
create the photos that he needed to do
for the image listing and the increase
in his sales that he's had is absolutely
absurd and he showed me look these are
the other top five competitors for
bamboo sheets and silk pillowcases in
the United States and look at how much
better my images are he's like well
because I wasn't constrained by reality
or physics I was able to just
perfectly dial in exactly what I wanted
through mid-journey and I got chat GPT
to write the prompts for Mid Journey so
you've got AIS telling AIS what to do so
I literally
the day before yesterday this is the 7th
of June I think on the 5th of June I
tried mid-journey for the first time
because I kept seeing articles about it
and I was thinking
how could I make I'm like could I
improve YouTube thumbnails for the
podcast messing around with this because
oftentimes as I'm sure you were your
staff knows I kind of want to have a
certain feel so I'll just Google image
search not Google image search [__] I'm
gonna create it in a day and a half and
I'm going to be super upfront honest I'm
an idiot I am
not an intelligent person I can like I
can Wrecking Ball my way through life in
a day and a half I have already created
some images that were beyond what I was
even thinking was possible
and that's 1.5 days
I mean with the least experienced user
on the planet yeah
yeah yeah it's terrifying man so I think
your point when it comes to talking
about media heterodox New Wave whatever
uh is that you're going to be able to
propagate a lot more news stories that
are going to be automatically generated
maybe this is the bulk of reporting the
boring stuff that just needs to be done
potentially will come from chat GPT or
some other sort of automated system
which has been trained on the biases
that humans have so it perpetuates and
propagates those existing biases so yeah
man this this Tucker thing is is
absolutely fascinating you know for I
think uh Matt Walsh is what is a woman
that the daily wire released over the
weekend to celebrate the start of pride
month that's right they released it
their Twitter allowed him to put it up
correct then Elon Musk retweeted it and
pinned it that is potentially the most
viewed documentary in human history now
because it got hundreds of millions I
think 100 million plays over the weekend
that's insane on Twitter the most viewed
documentary in human history I think
that's a metric for how much people
don't have faith anymore in traditional
media sources I truly think that it is
my concern is
with the AI
whether it's a good thing or bad thing
at some point
my thoughts will always shift back to
weaponization
and the volume of information that that
AI can create and could get the snowball
rolling downhill before people could
actually backtrack and figure it out for
most people it seems like they're
they're deeply held beliefs or about one
click deep and it's usually the first
search result so if you cut a volume of
information heading in the wrong
direction that was legitimately untrue
and I think it's a very uh fair thing to
say that the the Western World however
you would want to Define that has you
know there's an access to every belief
system and there's an access to those
belief systems and those belief systems
are also looking at Ai and leveraging Ai
and weaponing weaponizing AI I don't
know if we're intelligent enough as a
species to survive well think about it
this way right you make content on the
internet as do I
what you're trying to do is find a
balance somewhere between exactly what
you want to talk about and what your
interests are and some degree of what's
going to be at least partially
interesting to the audience you don't
want to compromise yourself so much you
get audience captured but you don't want
to be so Niche and completely
solipsistic that all you do is indulge
yourself over and over it's a blend
between the two right there is a third
participant in every conversation that
is the audience member that's listening
what you're trying to do is in some
regard on varying degrees reverse
engineer what the audience wants right
that's at least you're conscious of what
the audience wants so creators try to do
that and then algorithms try to deliver
content that people want to it so the
Creator predicts what the algorithm
needs based on what the audience wants
now you can remove the Creator all
together and just go algorithm direct to
Consumer right because you have no
restriction on how many different
iterations of content and images you
remember the Cambridge analytica thing
right where there was
um custom built memes around the exact
pain point that these particular
subgroups had around Hillary Clinton or
whoever it was and we're going to Target
them and create them and do all of the
rest of them but there's still a guy
somewhere sat working out what meme to
make what text to use dragging the image
in creating it putting it out there you
could have individual me right I know
Andy's profile and we will make a meme
or a series of memes just for him so I
think yeah but wait until the AI can
replace that individual and then you
have ai teaching other AI correct
correct and then we have to go bag a
robot for our water ration every day
yeah well dude
I think it's terrifying yeah it is and
when you think that within the space of
probably
three years it wouldn't be surprising if
most of the content created on the
Internet is no longer human generated if
you think that the internet is a
cesspool at the moment
at least you know the content that
you're consuming was made by another
person
yeah in the future it very well might be
the case that it's a rarity to not have
an automated oh my God this is a post
from a real person as opposed to an
automated uh bot of some kind there's
already
um
social media where you need to upload
images of your face I think maybe even
Instagram has this for verification now
to ensure that it's not bots so you have
to put a photo of your face up and maybe
a photo of your idea and what this does
is it ensures not only is it the same
person but if you try and duplicate it
you can't have more than one account or
some other some such which is trying to
restrict bot activity and that's just
now
I mean in one and a half days on
mid-journey I feel like I could create
both of those things full Universe give
me a half an hour and I could create
both of those things and then I mean
what is it what happens when it gets to
the point if we're not already edging
towards it already where people are
questioning every piece of information
that comes at them because they don't
know they don't know if it's biased I
think we're already there I think we're
already there too but I don't know if I
don't think we're training for it to get
better
I'm concerned that we're trending for it
to get worse and where does that land us
where do people go at that point to
actually get information about the world
that they can trust what you you
mentioned at the beginning that
the issue that people have is now an
abundance not scarcity right there's too
much information not too little
information and very quickly the over
the last sort of 30 years
the skill set that was most advantageous
to a human went from someone who was
able to seek out information to somebody
that is able to discern information
right it's now all about can you work
out how legitimate this is can you do
your sources or your checks a video from
a friend of mine went hyper viral as he
was talking about
um America is the third highest country
out of 193 Nations worldwide in gun
crime and if you were to remove the five
largest cities for gun crime from that
we would move from third down to 190th
or 189th or something like that it took
me one Google search to find out that
that's not true that's not even remote
it sounds [__] amazing yeah like oh
[__] let's just cut these cities out of
the U.S problem solved oh and there was
like a little bit of a they're mostly
blue cities and blah blah blah and don't
get me wrong dude if I'd heard it and
I've propagated tons and tons of stuff
like that I heard this like little
Zinger let me get it out there that
sounds cool uh but yeah that's you with
your human biases imagine if you had a
custom purpose built viral machine that
knew exactly the way to deliver it that
knew exactly what was going to trigger
you but going back to the Tucker
conversation right
you as somebody that's been in this
great nation longer than I have
How likely do you think it is that more
and more of the news guys I think Trevor
Noah recently left his show I think he
was released or maybe left uh Tucker
Carlson obviously released by Fox Now
doing his own thing
what do you think the future of these
sorts of news organizations would be if
people can go and make 40 times the
entire Prime Time ratings by going in
and yoloing it themselves with a couple
of students and a nice garage setup in
the house
maybe we don't need mainstream meter
anymore I think we're through the
Looking Glass on that one I I think that
Tucker and just those numbers alone
speak to
how much people are looking to a
traditional source and the traditional
models I mean I think they're mired in
bureaucracy I have been to the Fox News
Studio a few times I've done a couple of
written pieces for them and a couple of
uh in-person stuff and it is a large
building with a massive amount of people
that is constrained you know they have
they do have different uh journalistic
uh thresholds and barriers that they're
going to need to at least be able to
clear to present uh information and
ideas but they're way slower and there
are 100 soft and probably hard
boundaries on what their hosts can say
what they can do and I'm sure that the
money is good I have no idea what they
what they make but if somebody wants to
go out and have complete flexibility and
autonomy and probably actually make
orders of magnitude more money by being
on their own why would you admire
yourself in bureaucracy when you can put
together a small team and be you know
the first person through the door and
then reap the benefit of that are you on
a network your show uh no just the
internet no but you know what you know
what I mean like an iHot radio uh no I
put it up on the just the normal but any
sponsors that you do you handle yourself
either through an agency that's working
like as a consultant for you uh I used
to go through the agency route and then
just due to my relationship with evident
Black Rifle I just streamlined it and
was like you know what how about we just
do this so my point being that even
within our world the New Media thing
there are varying degrees of people
being bought now it comes to uh networks
and stuff like that the people that are
listening are concerned my favorite
creators on iHeartRadio maybe they're
part of a global conspiracy those guys
they help with production they help you
get guests and they sell ads right like
they're not they're not really it
increases yeah it increases your reach
largely in the experience I do have with
those things there are other platforms
and maybe those platforms whatever they
fall into whatever uh the globalists or
whatever it might be that doesn't mean
you as somebody who has content on that
platform is a part of that correct yeah
my point being that even within that you
found it easier to streamline even what
is already quite a streamlined way of
working so for somebody like Tucker I
would be really interested to know
why Twitter apart from the fact that you
can reach what will probably hit 100
million plays in 24 hours which there's
no way even on YouTube that you could do
that if you did a 100 million plays on
YouTube in 24 hours you'll be the number
one trending video worldwide on that
site
Mr BEAST's squid game video did
somewhere in the region of 70 million
but that was a movie level production
that was custom built for virality
Tucker just I mean it was a well-crafted
monologue he was actually talking about
this um Dam explosion
have you seen this so uh Tucker points
to kiev's uh possible role in the
kakovka damburst so if it was
intentional it was not a military tactic
it was an act of terrorism Tucker said
commenting on the incident blowing up
the dam may be bad for Ukraine but it
hurts Russia more and for precisely that
reason the Ukrainian government has
considered destroying it so basically
he's saying maybe this is a false flaggy
type thing yeah
the water level below this Dam has risen
by 12 meters which is that's going to
change some neighborhood layouts [__]
city
um that's what used to be a city yeah
correct correct you're now your granny's
now at the bottom of a lake totally um
but my point being that he's able to
talk about stuff that he wants yeah
without any restriction I don't know how
he's monetizing and I would love to know
why he chose Twitter apart from reach
reach is self-evident is he being paid
there's no ads as far as I can see I do
play for Twitter blue which means maybe
I'm ad-free so perhaps there would have
been pre-roll ads running before it
maybe people that have watched it that
don't pay for Twitter blue can tell us
or whatever if they saw Rad but you
didn't do a this episode is brought to
you by yeah anything there was no ads
Running part way through it could lead
to that I mean I don't I don't know a
whole lot about Tucker in the world that
he comes from I'm gonna assume he was
well taken care of when he was at Fox so
the move
might actually be to drive awareness
before the monetization can you imagine
the hammer you could swing in
negotiation like oh hey by the way I do
about 100 billion plays in 24 hours so
here's my rate oh you don't like my rate
next yeah dude so again for the people
that don't know this world I would guess
you could probably charge
between a 10 and a 20 CPM on that so
that's per thousand plays which is a
[__] ungodly yeah amount of money
let's just multiply that by a number
that has a lot of zeros yeah correct and
you know it doesn't matter how much
Tucker was being paid at Fox yeah I can
guarantee it wasn't that much nobody
nobody [__] talks no sorts of numbers
but I don't think he's in a rush to
monetize no no I think his move is
probably
build accumulate build Foundation
because then you can take it then you're
the you're the captain of your own ship
you have your hand on the wheel and
people can get on board but you get to
tell them what stateroom they're in as
opposed to the other way around yes and
think about it this way Tom Segura that
does your mom's house he pivoted from
comedian comedian with podcasts comedian
with very well produced podcast comedian
with podcast and other podcasts under it
to now Network yeah so he is vertically
integrating himself further and further
back up the chain smart yeah and you
know I don't know who runs who directs
the editorial policy at Fox News
something tells me that I've never seen
them on TV and I don't respect them as a
Creator oh they're not a Creator I bet
you it's a lawyer probably yeah but I
respect Tom Segura as a Creator I know
that he understands the craft so I go oh
yeah that that network has legitimacy
and Tucker Carlson will be able to lend
legitimacy to other people that come
along it's the same with uh Ben Shapiro
on The Daily Wire yeah right you know
Shapiro Jeremy boring Jeremy not
necessarily front-facing but no he can
he's done well crafted adverts and I've
seen him on cousin he can speak and you
know in a world of
uh social media where people want that
behind the scenes thing they want to
know Kim Kardashian's dog's name and
they want to know where Zac Efron goes
for coffee on blah blah and his
Instagram stories I think that that's I
think that gives a degree of resonance
yeah I'll be curious to see what he does
with it I mean what I guess the better
metric will be how does the second video
do
well if the algorithm's anything to go
by yeah that would be one other thing
that I haven't heard anybody talk about
one of my friends brought this up to me
Elon Musk pinned the what is a woman uh
documentary it's a tweet Elon musk's 20
year old
child
recently went through gender transition
really I did not know that yes
officially I think that might be a name
change or some sort of uh intervention
no one as far as I'm aware has brought
up the fact that Elon is quite sort of
forthcoming and vociferous about his
stance on uh trans stuff especially
around children
I wonder how much of that is driven by a
personal
investment
yeah adds another sort of families get
ugly right people who tell me that you
know they have a perfect family it's
like let's go back a few Generations
let's shake the branches a bit I can
tell you right now mine's got some
interesting branches as do they all
um so who knows I mean who knows the
dynamic between father and child are
they close are they antagonistic I mean
you've all seen both
you know the I watch that documentary I
don't find it to be controversial it's a
it's a man asking a legitimate question
looking for information valid reasonable
articulatable responses that can be
defended bring your idea let's bring it
into the light not the Shadows let's
investigate it let's ask questions
and see what remains
um but yeah I mean that's a that's an
issue that I can't in the people that I
have talked to
even inside of the trans community and
The Limited in um interaction that I
have had
the answer is very widely so it you know
who knows what's going on there between
child and father and it's also not
uncommon to have family members have
diametrically opposed beliefs which is
awesome Ed you know Thanksgiving
well I think uh political leaning is 60
heritable which means that you do have
most of the family in One Direction yeah
and then the outliers perhaps in another
load them up with some cocktails at
holiday parties and lunch just work it
out yeah I did friendsgiving last year
which was way better than Thanksgiving
yeah because you actually get to choose
your friends but you don't get to choose
your family this is a very true
statement it's a very true statement
yeah families get wild I get it I don't
know a single person who like again if
you dig enough far enough back you're
gonna have issues that are oftentimes
insurmountable
according to a new survey from the
American Cato Institute three in ten
Americans under 30 support the
installation of cameras in the home to
monitor wrongdoing strikingly the
Figures were markedly different among
the 18 to 30 cohort 3 and 10 support the
installation of surveillance cameras we
can probably also map this to emerging
support for intrusive digital
surveillance on the growing body of
studies indicating that faith in and
support for Democratic Norms is falling
with every generation even as the same
group turns against open debate and
academic freedom in other words there
has been a pronounced turn away from the
foundational liberal norms and towards a
baseline of authoritarian control and
surveillance in the name of safety care
and the avoidance of harm cater report
speculates that this shift is
generational noting that the over 45s
have a markedly different attitude to
surveillance and suggesting that this is
likely connected to the growing
prioritization of safety if you're used
to interacting on social media and
you're used to unaccountable Authority
and you've grown up partially online
you'll see it as normal to surrender a
measure of privacy for example allowing
social media to track your behavior in
exchange for access to the digital
services that enable your virtual Social
Life 3 and 10 want home surveillance
inside who decides what's right and
wrong
who decides what's the appropriate I
have three kids
um we're just getting into birthday
season my daughter just turned 15 my
middle son will turn 18 next month and
then my oldest son will turn 20. wildly
different and it's just different
between having boys and girls there's a
way that and I learned this lesson the
hard way you know I can talk to my sons
in a tone of voice
and not that I am aiming to do so but I
mean you get frustrated as a parent
right there's times where you're just
like you're at your Wit's End and I've
there have been times where I've been
very sharp and direct with my sons I
made that mistake one time with my
daughter and I watched her kind of Wilt
away and she was quite young but I
learned my lesson in that moment
but
so for me I I kind of have a and it's a
floating scale as they evolve as human
beings too and they're processing
but right and wrong
who who decides in that surveillance
what is wrongdoing what what's the
difference between wrongdoing and
difficult parenting decisions that you
have to make discipline
um it like and by discipline I'm not
talking like Jocko get up at 4 30 I'm
talking like taking nap Jocko you know
I'm talking like discipline disciplining
your dishes away yeah again or you know
hey you snuck out of the house at 13
years old and you were gone for two
hours and I caught you coming back in Oh
and it looks like you're shit-faced
these are hard parenting things that you
have to deal with
the idea of surveillance I think it was
a quote from Thomas Jefferson I came up
on my own podcast not too long ago but
it's essentially in a nutshell I'm sure
you've heard it as those who are willing
to sacrifice a small amount of freedom
for an increase in safety or deserving
of neither or security and I it's a such
a slippery slope first off I don't think
most people have any idea how much the
government is capable of collecting on
them right now
um for most people if you're listening
to this you need to assume that anything
you do on an electronic device is at
least being held somewhere I don't think
we have enough people or the Computing
bandwidth to look at it in real time but
we absolutely do retroactively and
people like oh we know the government
can't do that there's rules in the
Constitution it's like okay listen
there go onto the internet which you're
probably spending most of your life on
and actually you're consuming this
content on it anyway and Google the
Partnerships between America and our
allies and what we do when we want to
flirt the Constitution we have our
allies look inward because they have
your country might be a little bit
guilty if this Chris we might have a
partnership with a couple people across
the ocean that have access to the same
data that can look in because they don't
have to worry about the constitutional
rights of American citizens
I would imagine that we have a
reciprocal agreement with them as well
there are ways around all of this stuff
I have tried to teach my kids since they
had access to electronic devices that
anything you do on an electronic device
lasts forever and you should
be aware of that
um and I actually think it's a vast
overreach by the United States
government I think the government has
the ability to know far too much about
its citizens and people should be really
upset about that I really don't think
that there is a breadcrumb trail that
you can follow where if a government
knows more about you you are actually
safer as a people I think there is a
breadcrumb trail where you can follow
that the more the government knows about
you
probably the less secure that you are I
mean I'm sorry if you look at what's
going on in the FBI and I just had an
FBI agent who retired after 20 years on
my podcast and he was talking about the
shift in the higher levels of the FBI
government organizations can be
weaponized
in directions because of what the
government knows about people and their
beliefs and they shouldn't know those
things the patreon so we've got an
example uh
the websites that you visit are you a
member of the NRA are you a member of
this or that organization did you visit
this website
what have you posted what do you post
about what type of things do you they
can get a really good profile about who
you are as a person
and these large organizations people
forget often I think that they're just a
conglomerate of of individuals if you
get a large amount of individuals that
all think the same way pointed in One
Direction the result that you're going
to get from that is going to be biased
and I think it
people are so willing to allow the
government to look into their life in my
opinion the government should know
almost nothing about you and I but we
should know everything about the
government and what they're doing
and it's completely backwards right now
dude it's scary it's scary stepping over
here into America you guys have a much
closer read even if you think that most
Americans aren't sufficiently concerned
about what the government knows about
them on on sufficiently aware it's a
conversation that is much more surface
level much more front and center uh in
the UK it's just it's not a real
discussion we don't have we don't uphold
the virtues of freedom from tyranny and
all the rest of it in the same way that
you guys do
um now I have no idea about whether our
government is or is not surveilling us
as I can answer that for you yes
100 percent
well there we are we should we need to
have a conversation Britain we need to
have a conversation about freedom but I
mean the the especially the thing about
looking at your surveillance inside the
house and you make a really great point
that who determines what is or is not
acceptable behavior you know we've said
for quite a while
when it comes to having conversations on
the internet are there topics that
should be Beyond The Pale that you're
not allowed to talk about and even if
there are topics that you can talk about
de facto you can't talk about them
because of the sort of response so if
you start bringing up race and IQ that's
not going to be allowed if you start
bringing up stuff to do with
anti-Semitism or conspiracy theories to
do in certain ethnic groups that's also
not going to be particularly well liked
and you know
maybe very very good reasons that
it's hard to work out who is a good
actor that's genuinely having a good
faith interested conversation to try and
find out truth and who is a bad actor
that's trying to be the front end of the
funnel towards a KKK March right it's
difficult to pass part those two I think
the better question is would you rather
have conversations that may not be
agreeable to people happening in public
or have those same conversations that
are still going to happen occurring in
private
I think as a society we are better off
having them occur in public my theory is
pull things into the light if you push
things into the Shadows you can't really
see what's going on in there and I think
it creates an environment and room for
things to turn quite sour correct well
the the problem with censorship and the
reason that it doesn't work is that it
doesn't stop people thinking things it
just means that they no longer are
truthful about the things that they
think they pick and choose where they
tell the truth correct as I mean as we
all do but on on issues like that it's
yeah I would rather know
the racist that lives next door to me
then be surprised by it years down the
road yep so well you know
that is still even for the best meaning
amongst us a degree of pushback a
potential risk of cancellation
retribution in one regard or another
when you talk about these things in
public or online or whatever
but in the safety of your own home when
you're talking about this you have a
wife that is interesting and
philosophically you can have really
difficult discussions about cool things
we had a chat uh around the pool a
couple of weeks ago about the dysgenic
effect of abortion so the fact that
abortion is more easily accessed by
people who are richer people who are
richer are better able to do Family
Planning which actually means that
restricting access to abortion
encourages more working-class and
underclass children to accidentally be
born off the back of this which actually
means that you are propagating more
poverty uh than you are propagating more
rich people and there was maybe a
conspiracy that restricting this could
be done from top down to ensure that we
have enough workers to continue to do
the jobs that are laborious that the
bourgeoisie don't necessarily want to do
great word bourgeoisie yeah [__] yeah
but you go okay that that's like talking
about dysgenic that's the literally the
opposite of eugenic that's pretty sort
of trickery word then you're talking
about some stuff to do with group
conspiracy you're talking about you know
class differences and all of the rest of
it fascinating comments some super super
smart people sat around like three World
Poker Stars and a bunch of other people
and I was like [__] this is also really
really engaged in this conversation
listening to these people explain a
topic that I didn't really understand
but if that was part of this new home at
home installation surveillance thing and
the child or the young daughter who
doesn't like the idea that Mum and Dad
have got the friends around talking
about this with poker players
they press the button that oh they say I
want to report this for Thought crime or
whatever Tom Cruise comes in and you're
[__] he puts a Halo on you yes yes
correct oh that's what was that not
premonition what the [__] oh
majority report yes yes there is [__]
yeah also let's say we allow
let's go down this pipeline yes let's
say we tell the government for whatever
reason we lose our goddamn minds and we
say you know what U.S government
we're gonna let you put cameras in our
homes my [__] is wide open please
enter do you seriously I am a gape dear
one on the board for bourgeoisie one on
the word for gay referring to yourself
as a gape
oh my [__] god that's all I got for
today people I'm out here good
um what do you think the odds are of
them ever saying you know what we should
take these back out you know what this
is enough we have cameras
you know but these are these are 1080p
we need to upgrade this with some 8K and
honestly you know we were only kind of
getting some camera views how about the
bedroom we need a bedroom and we're
gonna need the audio too because you
know what if people are using non-verbal
what if it's non-verbal abuse of things
that are incorrect
I don't know of a history of of in the
U.S of giving the government an
incredible amount of power which in my
opinion
observation cameras in in the homes of
citizens is one insane but an incredible
amount of power I don't have an example
of them willingly giving it back correct
that is a razor blade that every step
that you take you are going to cut
yourself right it clicks down and it's
like okay it can only go One Direction
and it's not a good direction yeah
that's a tourniquet that you're putting
on and putting on and putting on and
putting on and the next thing you know
your limb is getting sawed off
in under the guise of safety so I think
the interesting uh part there was if
you're used to interacting on social
media you're used to unaccountable
Authority and if you've grown up online
you'll see it as normal to surrender a
measure of privacy in exchange for
Digital Services that enable your social
life it definitely seems to me that this
sort of generalized risk aversion uh
this optimization for convenience
Comfort
um
safety over Freedom slash genuine
privacy well they agree they don't know
a world without it correct you know my
all three of my kids again they they
didn't grow up my daughter probably the
most uh digitally native digitally
native my sons
not not a hundred percent but not as
much as my daughter they don't really
know or understand the world without
that device and what that device can
create for them it's hilarious when I
explain to them going to the library and
looking for books about you know the
career I wanted to go into when I was
younger they're like
why would you why would you do that or
bringing a friend to tell them where
you'll meet them yeah because once
you're out of the house you have no
other way of getting in contact with
them one of the most hilarious
conversations with my metal Stones
explaining to him a pager because that's
the dumbest [__] I've ever heard in my
life
oh wait a number that I have to call
that goes to a device that beeps you and
you'll call me on another device why
would you just combine this so I'm like
yeah well the Apes were still figuring
it out it took a while yeah yeah Steve
Jobs wasn't born yet yeah no he truly
thought that I was from the dumbest
species in the history of man when I was
explaining a pager to him yeah yeah and
you know if you've spent all of this
time with at your fingertips the most
controlled I could I choose what I get
exposed to anything that I am exposed to
which is remotely objectionable I can
report
so why can't I report things in the real
world if most of my social experiences
occur online most of the interactions
most of the stuff that I consume happens
on the internet on average Americans
spend 3 hours and 43 minutes per day on
their phones for Gen Z it's gonna be way
way way higher than that that's spread
across the entire nation 20 years ago
that time didn't exist so where's it
come from it's been squeezed out of real
life experiences right so if you spend
most of your time consuming things on
the internet and there's a report button
or a block button or a mute button
when you're walking through the real
world and you get exposed to things that
you're not happy with well
I can't where's the yeah [__] I I
also think you steal your ability to
develop resilience through the hardship
that you have to experience growing up I
mean growing up is not an easy thing
um I don't think it should be easy
how old are you 35 okay I'm sorry I got
10 years on you I'm the person that I am
today
because of the experiences that I went
through my parents went through
absolutely no effort to try to uh make
my life devoid of things that were
challenging if actually if I look back
on it
as a parent myself now I'm like holy
[__]
they actually for one I thought I was
Jason Bourne growing up I'm like I was I
was the Jason Bourne but I failed a
chromosome test so I was a little bit
short on my you know spy ability
I got away with nothing but they've let
me get away with a lot because they had
some boundaries that they were letting
me operate inside of
because they knew I had to fail and they
knew I had to suffer the consequences of
that failure they knew that not every
social interaction was going to be great
they knew I was going to have conflicts
and therefore have to develop conflict
resolution skills as I was growing up I
tripped I fell I scuffed myself up and I
learned from those things and I think if
you rob people of those opportunities
you are developing the softest
generation of human beings possible and
that's not that's not what I want for
anybody it's not what I want for this
nation for Any Nation or the world in
general
yeah I saw I quoted this in my
newsletter this week about these stats
of how few Americans can join 76 of
percent of American adults aged 17 to 24
either too obese to qualify or have
other medical issues or criminal
histories that would make them
ineligible to serve in the U.S armed
forces without a waiver I wish that
number was higher
I'm being dead serious I hear people I'm
all about inclusivity like I don't have
a problem with inclusivity it bothers me
when it's inclusivity for inclusivities
purpose and just for just so we can say
we're inclusive I think that the
military should be very exclusive I
think it should be extremely difficult
to be able to join and proceed down a
pipeline that you want to go down
because at the end of the day you I look
at what is it that you want to do and
what are the standards for that job what
are they based off of and I can only
speak through the lens of my own
previous military experience the
standards that are that our job was
based on and that we were held to came
from a Battlefield
and I don't give a [__] about your woke
ideology because none of that matters
when you're covered with your friends
brains not a single stretch of that [__]
matters whatsoever all of those
ideologies and all of these platforms
and and ideas that people want to put on
to the military just so they can say
that they did I think that they should
be removed I think it should be super
hard to get into the military we should
exclude most people from it because they
don't meet the physical standard the
uh whatever standards are listed with
the intelligence standard the
educational standards all of those
things that's a good thing I think we
are headed down the wrong path when we
just start opening the doors up and
letting all those people in because that
is not a military that is based to
operate in the environment that the
standards are based upon I had a
conversation with Heather McDonald who
has written a book called when race
trumps Merit and she's talking about how
affirmative action for different ethnic
groups is causing meritocracy to kind of
be thrown out of the window and it's it
kind of it's really uncomfortable
actually to to kind of go through
because there's a lot of pretty sort of
harsh and and disquieting stats that you
start to learn but the main thing that I
realized was
most people most sane people wouldn't
have a problem with the military having
an incredibly rigorous standard for
entry because they understand that if
you get this wrong mortal danger is on
the other side of it right if you have
somebody that is unable to keep up with
the rest of their platoon because of
their physical fitness or because
they've got diabetes or because they've
got a gluten intolerance or whatever
that person puts themselves into
everybody else at risk but really almost
all Industries are just a difference of
degree not a difference of kind away
from that so she used this example of
underrepresentation within Alzheimer
research or Parkinson's research
but the problem that you have if you
start to do an excessive amount of
affirmative action in that especially if
you completely disregard or mostly
disregard meritocracy is that you slow
down Parkinson's and Alzheimer's
research which is directly impacting
people's quality of life yeah so okay
it's not mortal danger but it's like
Health span and lifespan and it's mortal
danger for some precisely so you go okay
and then so where at which point all the
way down to the checkout operator you
know like at what point do we say that
this doesn't have a operating based on
Merit doesn't have a place to be within
this system it's really hard to find a
line at which you go yeah it's about
there it's about the person that
professionally does croak crochet or
[__] bakes cakes or something like
that you know
I mean I I think that the the
conversation should be had and it's
probably going to be a shifting scale
depending on what you're talking about
um you know should it be as difficult to
join the military as it is to
work at a Dunkin Donuts no right like we
need to be able to have a sliding scale
we're an advanced species we have the
ability to think
let's use that skill a little bit more
did you see that
um criticism around
Navy SEAL selection being too harsh uh
as seals were sprayed with tear gas and
forced to sing Happy Birthday yeah you
see this video is [__] awesome
what's your thoughts on that
um I mean I say that a little bit
tongue-in-cheek first off anybody who's
been through that pipeline has
experienced that and there's a few ways
that you can look at it from my
understanding what I will say is this
from my understanding from what I have
heard from other instructors that were
there
those particular instructors instructors
were a little bit off the reservation
and this can happen because instructors
again you wear this blue and gold
t-shirt in your hat and your shorts and
you roll your socks it's a super dumb
way and
it's just people they might all look the
same to the outside perspective but just
because you're an instructor or even a
seal doesn't mean that you're a good
person by any stretch you get the wrong
person in the wrong role bad [__] is
going to happen so the amount of Cs gas
that they were exposed to from my
understanding exceeded what the
um what do they call it it's a
of course I can't remember right now
it's every it's an evolution cheat so
everything that happens in Seal training
that the room for imagination
is almost non-existent it's basically
like pull the three ring binder here is
what we are trying to accomplish it like
you know the mission statement here's
what we're trying to accomplish here's
our boundaries this is the evolution
this is what it is this is how long
we're going to do it for the students
don't know this so as a student it's
very chaotic I didn't know this until I
went back as an instructor I'm like holy
[__] like basically everything limits to
this the limits are unbelievable and the
safety net should be
incredibly robust but also invisible to
the students there's a portion of that
train I'm like yeah maybe you should
feel like you're gonna die you're not
going to die we're not going to we're
gonna do our absolute utmost to prevent
you from dying even though it does
happen
um but there's a psychological test
there as well it's a physical and mental
Crucible so
I have no issue with people being
exposed to CS gas because I was exposed
to CS gas uh the third phase of training
occurs out on San Clemente Island which
is where that video came from the
problem I have with it is
the training and those Evolution sheets
and again those standards
you can draw a very precise breadcrumb
trail to the why why do we expose people
to CS gas and training well because one
it's very common and the first time that
you're exposed to it probably shouldn't
be for real so what do we need to do we
should expose it to people in a training
environment where we can have a robust
medical staff
problem is from my understanding they
involve people in that that actually
weren't necessarily directly involved in
the training pipeline they exposed them
to far too much gas
and one of the biggest issues I have
with it is that there was some [__]
idiot there filming it with a cell phone
do your job because I tell you right now
filming it for your Instagram page is
not your job and I don't know what you
think is going to come from that and the
reason they make you sing happy birthday
is that requires you inhale and exhale
it's the same they do that it's is that
what you did uh within it they didn't
have a sing Happy Birthday they like
there's all these like frog Man songs
that you sing when you're in training
and they'll just have you do something
that increases your respiration because
there's some people out there that can
hold their breath a really long time
now that holding your breath in an
environment like it's still it's on your
clothes it's it sucks
what's it like what's it what's it burns
um have you ever uh well I was
my sister one time had like a little uh
mace spray thing and I I don't mind I
had it in my pocket and I sprayed it on
myself and then wiped my eyes I was
gonna say have you ever done that but
most people haven't because they're not
idiots no so
it would be it's uh it burns you it it
really burns your eyes water an
unbelievable amount
um within a few seconds you'll be
questioning how it's possible that your
body creates as much mucus as coming out
of your body
um you cough it can make seem like
people it's hard to breathe for some
people they describe it as they're
inhaling like Flames from this like very
hot
is it is it going to kill you unless you
have an underlying medical condition I
think it's so highly unlikely does it
feel like it's going to kill you
probably to some people and that's the
point we have to expose students to
those things that they may be exposed to
overseas I would rather have a student
have that experience and know
the cognitive decline the physical
decline the emotional Decline and the
impact that it's going to have on their
ability to do their job in training
before it happens in real life
now if the instructor staff went one
percent beyond what is on that Evolution
sheet then they are wrong for doing that
because that evolution is based on that
real world requirement they use 5x the
gas or 10x the gas then they should be
punished for that particular activity
but the the evolution and of itself is
essential
now somebody looking at that on
Instagram could be like oh well that
looks like torches like you don't know
anything about this job you're I'm not
saying your opinion isn't valid I'm just
not going to pay any attention to it
because you don't know what you're
talking about
unidentified anomalous phenomena are we
talking about aliens yeah [__] yeah God
I hope they're real yeah why are people
scared of aliens I would have one on the
podcast yeah I don't know what the [__]
we talk about but I mean
if there's aliens out there which I
think there are mathematically I think
it's improbable that we are alone out
here it's uh our ability as a species to
think that we are so incredibly unique
shocks me sometimes
if they're here visiting I have to
believe that they are
more advanced than we are I would assume
I mean obviously technologically because
they're covering a distance that we are
not capable of covering
um it seems like they are able to evade
detection to a degree and I would
honestly guess that if we are seeing
them it's because they would want us to
see them
but both of those things combined lead
me to believe like if they wanted to
[__] us up they probably already could
have and would have
so
I don't know I think maybe like we're
the comedy planet to them like you win a
prize on some other planet they're like
dude you just won the best prize ever
we're going to send you to this other
planet and you're not going to believe
the [__] that you're gonna see and so
they come and they watch and they laugh
and they go back and they tell Tales of
how dumb we are but it doesn't work like
like let's get on like this is awesome
sit down and like have a chat with me or
like Bluetooth my mind or wherever that
works I'm not interested in the probing
part you know but like and I don't know
why that was such a narrative early on
yeah kind of like a Freudian thing that
wasn't it I got taken up into the sky
they levitated me up and the first thing
that they did always right at the ass
yeah it's like they were they were
forced to be a gape
using a verb as a noun you have so few
times in life to use that word that I
think you should seize as much as
possible let's get it in a few more
times yeah we finish up so David grush
this guy yeah that's the dude yep
I've watched a good bit of stuff on him
and his story
in your professional opinion yep
how reliable do you think that this
particular person's
story security access clearance all the
rest of it is so a very limited
knowledge of him I actually was exposed
to his videos for the first time
yesterday
um in a very in a very brief article
um so he was in the Air Force I think he
was an intelligence officer he held a TS
SCI clearance and apparently he worked
for a program that was peripheral or
directly involved in identifying uaps is
what I think they call call it aliens
you know
military officer cool intelligence
officer great TS SEI clearance what's up
it's top secret special
compartmentalized information
and
it sounds like a big deal but honestly
it's not I mean if you look at the uh
not too long ago there was a national
Guardsman the the intelligence League he
was uh he had a TS SEI clearance and
access to these databases because
oftentimes you know to hold certain jobs
you have to have certain clearances it's
the same clearance that I had when I was
uh at the Seal team on the east coast
and it takes about two years to actually
get to clearance so oftentimes you'll
get the job and they'll just give you an
interim clearance meaning you have the
clearance and access to the stuff as if
you edit the background investigation
had been complete but then it takes like
two years to catch up to it it's not an
uncommon clearance it's cool to say and
right out top TS SCI clearance he must
know everything
I was read into with that clearance in
the course of 17 years
I was read into a few programs that
offline I can give you a few Google
search words and you would literally be
able to find the information on the
internet
people's thoughts that
Jason Bourne is like out there
maybe there is in my experience that's
not the case it's a combination and like
this Vice of like 60 people's careers
jammed into one unique little coin and
that's just not the way that it works so
I don't doubt that he might have worked
on a program that was basically around
um identifying unidentified [__] in the
air like that's probably a good idea
okay we're kind of seeing these things
that we don't know what they are let's
put together some people to do that from
my understanding that was nested inside
of the Air Force what he was referencing
in the video
and what he seems to be referencing when
he kind of made like the the tour of uh
the media tours well there's this other
program and it's their job to actually
collect things and what I'm hearing is
from these people these senior officers
they are telling me about things that
they saw and for me personally now we're
talking like second and third hand
information it's like listen he's like
well we weren't read into this program
and we weren't we weren't allowed access
to that one and that's totally common
compartment to the C yeah the
compartmentalization is totally common
status yeah I
was not read into programs that other
people the commands that I was read into
because there's two things you have to
have you have to have this appropriate
security clearance but then also the
need to know just because you have a
tssci doesn't mean you're like walking
into a skiff which is like a room about
this size where they
keep all this dumb secret [__] or access
to programs you don't just get to go
like oh hey uh yeah I'll be in this gift
for the next three hours and you're just
thumbing through stuff that's like a
library yeah it's not the way that it
works so if this guy's job which I don't
doubt that he held that job
and I don't even necessarily doubt that
other people would be coming up to him
and saying to him hey this is what I saw
and and this is what I did but it's not
uncommon that they are going to separate
programs that might have something to do
with each other
but the best way to keep a secret is to
keep it compartmentalized and separate
like I'm sure that even when it went
back to uh you know creating the first
the Manhattan Project I bet you there
were people who were working on that
project that years later were like oh
[__] I actually designed me well I
designed my housing that was my [__]
I designed that wire they had no idea
why because it was compartmentalized why
because we were trying to keep it a
secret so
I personally don't think that we're
alone I hope that we're not alone like I
would legitimately like what's up dude
let's go have a beer alien do you drink
beer like what's going on here I don't
think there's as much to be scared of as
people may think but these people coming
forward like I have all the secret
information
and then I'm not gonna actually give you
a shred of it
to me puts their legitimacy in question
anybody that doesn't have first-hand
knowledge of something but there's some
other interesting stuff that in order to
be able to communicate this information
he had to get I think it's Department of
Defense or
Security Homeland Security clearance to
be able to say these things and he was
allowed that's not much of a
whistleblower then no so he was allowed
to say these things yes they said so
they have determined that what he was
going to say is not classified
information yeah because he had to get
the clearance in order to be able to get
this out at least this is what was
reported on Fox News so then what the
hell is actually going on Joe's theory
is that they're trying to steal more
money from us
who
the government they're trying to
distract us with aliens while they pass
some other [__] that takes more money
from us
he thinks it's a false look over there
the aliens are over there the debt
ceiling nobody needs to see this he his
he's Landing more on I think this is
actually an intelligence operation
trying to point our uh attention false
flag yeah actually in another Direction
but psychological false flag
yeah well here's the thing what was that
um that president that said uh if only
we were attacked by an alien force we
would how quickly would Humanity's
differences be forgotten so it was maybe
Reagan or somebody like that anyway uh
the point being that at the moment
because largely life is very comfortable
and there is no existential threat apart
from the ones that people make up and
population collapse uh apart from the
ones that people are concerned about
that are in the news
the only enemies that people have are
the ones inside right the ones internal
to their Nation I actually think that if
you were to say there is a an alien
civilization that's out there we're not
sure if it's hostile or if it's uh
benign
you would actually end up with quite a
bit of cohesion because For the First
Time Ever humans tribal biases are able
to be deployed against something other
than humans well it's a threat for the
entire population just not one segment
of the population correct people are
brought together much more over shared
hatreds than shared Labs at the moment
there is more hatred than there is love
but if the hatred could be directed at
something in the sky or somebody out
there you could white pill this and say
oh you know there's actually a potential
good that comes out of this but yeah I I
don't know man it's there's a lot of
different people that are part of this
story like this lady that's involved
that was helped to feed David this
information is this lady that's been a
part of sort of a UFO truth or
conspiracy theory for many years well
it's so let's say that let's play this
out as if everything he's saying is true
so he was not part of the program
specifically but he's hearing that there
is a program that exists somewhere
nested inside of the dod
that they go out and they retrieve all
of these things for one that would be
an enormous operation first off you'd
have to staff it and man it so we're
talking you'd have to have aircraft
specifically dedicated for that so you'd
have people up front flying the aircraft
you'd have people in the back of the
aircraft and the people in the back of
the aircraft are going to be probably
Junior personnel and my point in all
this is like the more people that see
this the more people that like try to
keep a secret among five people and then
add a zero to that and then add a zero
to that how is this director of leakage
that's what I'm saying like you're
trying to tell me that somewhere there
it's nested inside of the dod and they
have a dedicated Wing that's doing this
and they're flying all over the place
and nobody
can give me one concrete shred of
evidence
well that's
uh you said earlier on about people need
to be able to sort of hold two thoughts
in their mind at once this is a
relatively difficult one for some people
some of the time to do which is
the government and the New World Order
is unbelievably sophisticated and able
to coordinate itself so that Global
Health passports and microchips in our
vaccines and aliens are able to be kept
from us
and also the government is so useless
that I wouldn't trust them with anything
and they are completely incompetent in
all of the recipes like Yo which one is
it yeah which one is it is it that
they're able to coordinate a half
thousand person operation to be able to
go and retrieve the most valuable
artifact of non-human origin ever
discovered even including meteors in in
plain sight we haven't figured it out
yet
and not a single not a single verifiable
leak yeah or is it that they're
completely useless and nobody should
ever be trusted and the government needs
to get the [__] out of my life I'm
totally fine with both of those things
being true that there can be portions of
it that do both
in my opinion what is it hanlon's razor
did not attribute to malice that which
can be explained by stupidity it's like
do not attribute to conspiracy that
which can be explained by people that
just really really really are good at
lying
agreed and you know there could be a
third option somewhere in between those
two where you kind of said it there's a
small because the government and these
organizations are just people would it
be possible to find people that are
super capable and competent and operate
well inside of an incompetent government
yes well that's the C again right that's
what I'm saying yes you could
but man I
my personal [__] meter goes off
pretty pretty rapidly and also and I
don't know why there was something about
the way that the individual was talking
about it that just was like the good
Instinct yeah it's like I don't know man
maybe he's telling that maybe he's
talking about things he truly believes
uh but there was there was something
about it that rung off to me that's
always something that I find interesting
you know and there's a a missing child
and the parents go out and they do the
Press tour there's this a girl called
Madeleine McCann in the UK very famous
child that went missing I think in
Turkey in sort of the mid 90s and the
number of conspiracies about her parents
that they'd kidnapped her they'd sold
her into slavery or they'd been
negligent to her or some of the [__]
which very well may be true
um and people were analyzing how they'd
done their press conferences and one of
the interesting things I reflected on
there is they were saying these people
are unreliable actors look at it nobody
nobody would act this way when giving a
press conference about their last
daughter I'm like oh sorry hang on
where's the [__] Handbook of examples
of how people are supposed to normally
behave yeah
studies missing like because there's two
they've either
killed a chopped her up and and spread
her in the sea or she's been stolen
right like I can give you way more
options than that
let's be creative how are you you're the
guy you're the guy that would dispose of
the body so but my point being like how
how are you supposed to behave like how
do you behave and the same thing goes
for this guy so you know in terms of
some degrees of freedom let's say that
you do have these you know again do not
attribute to malice that which can be
explained by stupidity or perhaps um
incompetence yeah or culpability or or
believability from this guy you know he
he could be telling the truth so you've
been given this information by these
people that have said that this is true
they seem reputable to you perhaps they
also believe that it is reputable
perhaps it's second or third hand from
them you don't know where it goes
what's the playbook for how you're
typically supposed to be able to give an
interview to the Press claiming that
this is potentially the first alien
craft but the other thing what was it he
said he said something about there's
been a
non-human remember that you know he's
almost read it like a novel it was like
there's been uh he said basically a
pilot exactly and uh
you know that's the same in this one I'm
like is this a [__] Thriller novel or
something well also don't forget you
know both you and I I'm used to being
around cameras like they don't bother me
anymore I could only imagine let's say
let's again go down the
thought process of he everything he has
is the truth and he is actually trying
to be a whistleblower and this is the
first time he's ever had a camera in
front of his face you're going to ask a
little you're gonna act a little awkward
yeah yeah
NASA's got this panel for uaps
apparently and they are encouraging
commercial pilots to come forward did
you talk about this do you know so this
is pretty interesting so NASA's got this
panel right there's these uaps that are
happening again this may be a part of
the conspiracy to the false flag thing
but what they're doing is it seems like
commercial pilots because they spend way
more time in the skies than all
militaries combined if I have [__]
huge margin
they observe a variety of strange aerial
phenomena but there is a stigma in the
commercial Aviation Community around
Pilots submitting this yeah because
they're gonna think you're crazy in
February alone the FAA had 68 reports
One commercial pilots so this is NASA
trying to encourage a cultural shift
amongst commercial pilots for them to
come forward so that they're going to be
less reluctant to report it because
again you're going to be shunned and
maybe mocked as a crazy person uh and
yeah in February alone the FAA had 68
reports of uh uaps by commercial pilots
I think we should embrace it I I mean
if we're not alone and they want to come
here I don't think we're going to stop
them so let's embrace the fact that it's
possible and you know the commercial
pilots yeah I think for years the stigma
has been oh you believe in aliens
tractor meme huh probe yeah I get it
yeah totally so
I think I actually think it's a really
good thing
um I actually have quite a bit of flying
experience and sometimes you see weird
[__] up there report it and what you're
going to get is probably the vast
majority of those things are things that
were reported that can be explained but
you might get a small minority of them
where you can look into it and we can
develop a better understanding of
whether or not we are alone or not just
just tell the goddamn truth if you see
something you'll understand
that's unrecognizable make a report on
it and
yeah I per I just
I'd rather lean into it
make some popcorn invite them down like
why not
yeah man it's interesting that it's
everything seems to be picking up speed
whether it be conversations about Ai and
recursive self-improvement whether it's
nanotechnology or bio weapons or natural
pandemics or engineered pandemic so
aliens or whatever
um
I think the next
five to ten years is going to be a real
fever pitch for stuff because if it
keeps increasing if it keeps I mean
aren't we at vertical yeah it's the
inflection is feeling pretty like the
hockey stick is very hockey sticky at
the moment yeah I don't know how much
more vertical that we can get yeah it's
gonna I would describe it as wild it's
going to be a wild time I'm glad that I
live in a remote section of Montana
maybe give me a little bit of butter
yeah [__] yeah yeah up in the
Northwestern section it's how do you
feel just a little physical buffer not
saying this they can come visit me there
too I actually prefer that they did
Welcome arms come on in but it's going
to be a little bit you're going to be
later in the day yeah it'll buy me a
little time geographically
topographically to buy me a little bit
of time
what is your
opinion on this sort of I'm seeing this
more and more especially since I've
moved to America this sort of very it's
not quite being a prepper
but it's
kind of being prepared no it's like
military lopping it's like people people
that like to wear sort of tactical wear
as casual wear uh people who are maybe
non-military but could be relatively
wealthy but spending a bit of time sort
of surrounding themselves with military
or yeah or with firearms and doing lots
of tactical training and stuff like that
it's a it's a tenuous balance because it
can absolutely be taken too far I mean
the things that
get reported are like individual berries
a school bus and makes it into a bunker
and lives out of that and is putting
camel paint on every day and waiting in
the bushes for an unseen government
entity that's probably never going to
come because they know you're crazy and
you're isolated it's like oh the guy's
in this trench again we don't need to go
out Japanese uh the Vietnamese Soldier
or whatever so yeah yeah there's one in
Guam too I think he finally came out of
the cave like 20 years later yeah so
that would be I think like the
pejorative of prepper because it
definitely I think it does have a
pejorative slant to it
but I also think
that people should take a very holistic
view of how much they rely on other
people to be able to do their day-to-day
and if people do that it's kind of
shocking I mean
water power food housing Transportation
information all of these things
and I'm not saying that everybody needs
to have a diesel generator in their
apartment and an HF radio set and 60
days worth of food and somehow you're
siphoning like gutter water into your
house into 55 gallon drums
there's a balance in between the like so
there's a and b right there's there's a
balance in between I think
and it kind of goes back to resilient
resiliency if there was a catastrophe
and actually I was a I was down here a
couple years ago when Texas got the they
had like an inch of ice on the ground
and it was Armageddon snow you know it
almost ground people did these people to
[__] with cold weather well but not I
mean there's there's that aspect of it
let's remember who said that it wasn't
me but
but they're also like the infrastructure
like when the power went out for four
days people were losing their [__]
minds it's like you can actually prepare
yourself
even just through knowledge
on how to navigate something like that
you don't have to have all of those
things I think you should have I mean so
where I live for example is slightly
different
um there are places in Montana that can
get a little Western physically and
metaphorically in response time from
First Responders is going to be 45
minutes to an hour depending on where
you're at you need to in certain times a
year have the ability to handle your own
[__] until a higher level of care comes
and that might be a couple of days so I
think in that environment you need to at
the very least think in those
considerations but I just I I hate
people who just
willingly Outsource everything that they
need for their life to somebody else and
they don't take any ownership of it and
then there's the other foreign like
you're talking about the people who want
to wear
you know military Flair and regalia and
they want to talk about a civil war
while they're posting pictures of
themself on the [__] internet with
their Optics on their rifles on
backwards it's like I'll send you plenty
of them it's it's a hobby of mine to
look at that you know it's I hate people
who call who are calling for Civil War
people have no idea
what it is that they are asking for they
have no idea what that would actually
look like and for some reason they seem
to think that it would save the country
as opposed to just destroy the country
um I had a conversation with a friend
who spent a lot of time shooting and is
very responsible and he sort of talked
me through his progression that he had
of becoming a gun owner and then
becoming sort of competent and then
proficient and then kind of where he's
at now uh and he was saying that he's
fluxed in his
um desire for an incident to occur an
awful lot and it's kind of given him
emotional and existential Whiplash uh
because of what's happened and I
mentioned to him and I'm sure that
you'll be familiar with this as well
that there are some people who spending
a bit of time around firearms and when
I'm around them I get a sense of hunger
they want something to happen for
something to kick off because they've
done all of this training and they've
spent all of this time thinking about
the bad guy and you you roll BJJ you
want to compete right you you do boxing
you want to get into the ring you don't
just hit the pads all the time you want
to actually and I mentioned it to him
and he said uh I've actually become
as I've got super out into expert level
I've become more and more reticent
around using my firearm because I know
that that's the last time I'm probably
ever going to pull the trigger yeah if I
shoot a person even if it's in the most
unequivocable self-defense ever
I'm probably not going to be able to
shoot another firearm again in my entire
life and you still may lose in Civil
Court yep I have uh I have been around
more weapons-based violence than almost
every human being on the face of the
planet and I say that because almost
nobody is actually exposed to it but in
the job that I came from that was
literally if at the end of the day if
you refine everything down and what is
it that what was our job
it was to find fix and finish
individuals in locations where they
thought that they were the most secure
to find somebody locate them in space
and time go to their front front door
and depending on how they behave once we
cross that front door either take them
into custody or [__] kill them
and if you do that for long enough the
last thing that you ever want to do is
be around gun violence again I don't
want to and Montana is a constitutional
carry state
I carry
um
but I don't ever want to have to pull my
gun out on a human being ever again it
is not and I I do agree with you there
are people who have this idealistic like
they're going to be in like like doing a
gun shoot at the okay Corral it's like
oh dude and uh a good friend of mine uh
Mike Glover who is actually the owner of
field Craft Survival this weekend we are
doing some scenario Based training where
I live up in Kalispell and we did one a
few weeks ago and before that I had
helped him out at another one and it's
it's the morning starts with an
introduction to pistols and then my wife
teaches an introduction to jiu jitsu and
then they do scenario Based training
with somebody in a red suit that may
have a gun they may not have a gun these
people have a gun on them with
simunition rounds the wax bullets that
sting like a [__] Varsity moves
to put him in the freezer the night
before that's an aside that's a tip for
anybody out there who still trains with
Sim rounds put them in the freezer
you'll drop them like a sniper shot to
the chest
the number of people
who that was their first time
ever actually making a decision should I
pull this gun out and should I use it
and the number of people that would have
spent their remaining days in prison for
murder is startling what's a typical
scenario
uh I don't want to give too much of it
away but I'll give you a broad one you
are in a parking lot um and usually
he'll pair this up with a male and a
female the female will have a bag in her
hand and somebody starts approaching you
pretty aggressively asking for money hey
and the series like usually coming out
of a grocery store and you have vehicles
on each side so a little bit of a
confined environment somebody is coming
directly at you
and go the person's loud they're coming
at you aggressively and the beauty of
the last uh the last time we ran this is
that the role player was actually a
sheriff a local sheriff so he could
really speak to here's what's going to
happen when law enforcement shows up
uh go ahead and uh show me your hands
turn around
so he could give that and so the person
approaches I've seen it go down now
three times
every one of those times the person gets
shot
they do not have a weapon now and there
are plenty of times where that is
completely and utterly justifiable and I
would also say
in that situation it depends on if
you're a man and a woman
um
for women
absent and incredible amount of training
and even then there is a size strength
and weight difference that cannot be
overcome the only thing that you really
can do to increase survivability is to
introduce a tool into that environment
the level is that playing field so if it
was just a woman
um and in some of the other scenarios
that was the case and the results it was
interesting they they shoot early and
sometimes they need to to survive but in
this situation it was interesting to see
people go from zero to one hundred
I mean to me like the old-fashioned
Spartan Kick in that particular
situation would have been amazing
because the role player was briefed if
they do anything that is Hands-On go to
the ground and the threat is over I
never got to that point I got shot every
time
it's a tough one and you got to think
about this from the perspective of most
security cam footage is not going to
have audio so you have to think about
this from 12 people looking at this
no audio I'm not hearing this person not
hearing anything in your face and saying
give me your [__] money and I'm gonna
kill you and I'm a blah blah they don't
hear any of that
do you want to roll the dice and gamble
with your life with that most people
will go and they purchase a gun and
another thing I think that should be
required is actually a safe to put the
gun in it's just those two Dimensions
yeah it should be it's it's a tool
that's designed to take life and that's
okay let's just treat it with the
appropriate amount of respect
but
you know this it's people will buy a gun
they'll train with it a little bit if at
all and they think that it's for lack of
a better term a Harry Potter wand they
can pull it out and just boom and it's
going to solve all these problems I
think the vast majority of time if you
were to pull it out it's going to
introduce problems into your life that
you're going to spend years trying to
navigate your way out of if you're even
successful it's not a magic tool it is a
tool but it's not magic and there's a
lot of pros and cons to it and the
people that I know who are the most
versed in violence whether it's with
their hands or with tools they actually
want nothing to do with it
yeah I'd remember a Jocko video where
he's talking about
um what to do if somebody gets
aggressive in public yeah run away every
single piece of advice involved just
leaving he's a dangerous man he does not
it's like
you know we I I've been doing Jiu Jitsu
now for almost five years I go and I
wear these like cool little pajamas with
my buddies and it's like let's not roll
outside let's go get on this padding and
also like we're gonna play by the same
rules right like you're not gonna punch
me in the face and I'm not biting no
headbutting yeah totally I'm not gonna
grab your dick and twist it off it's
like okay we're like we're friends we're
trying to get better
I don't want to go roll around in a
parking lot that [__] hurts even if I
know how to handle myself I don't
actually want to touch somebody who
appears to be crazy because I don't know
if they just bathe in their own [__] you
know I don't want any part of that like
people who know the most about violence
understand how how catastrophically bad
it can go and you can also win a
physical fight and a gunfight and lose
in the grander scheme of things better
to avoid at all costs Mike sent me uh
did you get the bag did you get the pack
of his new book how [__] cool is that
thing that little
yeah it has the little visor panels yeah
it's so [__] cool and so again where
I live I need to have because of the
distance of you know to First Response I
need to have
the ability to at least maintain care or
provide a level of care until a higher
level shows up so I have that stuff all
over my vehicles and I hope that I never
use it I don't ever want to use that
stuff and I'm not hoping that um like
driving around every corner like ah damn
it there's no T-boned wreck here there's
no motorcyclist with his legs sticking
that's an interesting point the fact if
if all that you wanted was to be able to
be righteous why are people not as
excited for the potential to step in and
tourniquet someone as they offer the
potential to step in and shoot someone
the number of people I'll ask well the
number of people they also have an
unrealistic understanding like I'm not a
fan of Statistics because they can be
highly skewed and weaponized as well but
if you look at something that you are
going to carry on yourself every single
day I would recommend Band-Aids and
tourniquets to people a lot more than I
would guns and I'm not saying that one
is more valuable than the other but if I
personally have come upon multiple
wrecks in the U.S where I have rendered
Aid to people and zero gunfights
that's the stats that most people are
going to live in however if you get into
a gunfight I hope you have a [__] gun
because if not it's not going to go your
way but you're so much more likely to be
able to render Aid to somebody and help
their life than be in a situation where
somebody's life needs to be taken well
that's another point that I I never
really realized until I came to America
which is the
externality of road rage and of getting
pissed at somebody on the road tell me
there's no road rage oh no there's Road
there's tons of Roads okay Britain but
I'm just checking but people are like it
never escalates right like no one's no
one's [__] swerving over in front of
your car and telling you to get out of
the [__] car [__] well but when
you're here I regularly see uh I never
forget it man it was the first week that
I arrived in Texas and we're pulled up
at a junction and up next to us posit
this massive Mexican guy no helmet on on
a trike one of those trikes LED lights
on it music splar and I was like this
guy is pretty [__] cool he's had
their big [__] tattoos all over his
arms like this
and he had a [__] handgun just open
carry on his hip and I thought
he gets to go wherever he wants like if
he wants to go in front of us he gets to
go in front of us if he wants to stop
for a while and have a cigarette he also
gets to do that too yeah that there is
an undertone
of mortal danger in America
that I didn't notice in the uh in the UK
and now this may be because it's simply
an alien place to me it's new I haven't
acclimatized or the whatever
but the homeless population is more
forthcoming and more dangerous by an
absolute country mild they're more
shuffly they're more skitsy they're more
like come up to you and [__] try and
do stuff to you but they'll get right up
in your face it literally happened to my
wife and I last night you go on Sixth
Street
uh yeah actually we're close to Sixth
Street good guess the epicenter of the
crazy here in Austin but here's the
thing like my wife is [__] on it a
woman came by she was kind of getting
aggressive to people sitting next to us
the woman came up and asked us for money
I took a tone of voice with that
individual that indicated you're gonna
get one answer from me and one answer
and that's it she continued on and like
it started building like you know what
let's get the [__] out of here
almost all violent confrontations can be
avoided
situational awareness and just you know
don't put yourself in a it's like you
think something's going south
go north
you know get out of there
do you have a cross paths with dead
Castro in the sales yeah yeah we were uh
I was a buds instructor and he was an
sqt instructor so same
to uh
two wheels of the same training vehicle
okay yeah what was that like what was
working with him never worked with him
directly so I taught basic the basic
training basic underwater demolition
slash seal which is the six month
pipeline he taught sqt which was seal
qualification training so think of it as
initial Crucible very very little
knowledge about the actual job sqt was
I'm not going to say a finishing school
because you leave their
you have a lot of knowledge but no
experience it's like
an associate's degree it's not a masters
it's not a PhD like it's the most
dangerous point in your career actually
as I'm sure it is in law or in medicine
where you have a lot of book knowledge
and Zero Street smarts you're just super
excited to be given some tools that are
yeah like a machine gun you know
you're the most dangerous time in my
career was when I knew everything I
would have told you that but had done
nothing and they're like here's a gun
I'm like this is [__] everything I
thought it was gonna be
everything I thought it could be
[__] yeah well you were very heavily
involved in CrossFit for a very for a
long time I don't know if they would
describe it like that I worked for the
organization for about eight years I
started off for about four years of that
teaching the conceptual Foundation at
the seminars so giving the lectures in
the weekend seminars and then I
transitioned after a deployment in 2010.
to more of business like sponsorships I
manage the charitable initiatives for a
little bit so much less consumer facing
if the consumer facing is the
deliverables on the weekends and much
more to the business and then uh was the
pilot for Greg for
two and a half maybe three years along
those pilots flying oh wow really yeah
he um so CrossFit was founded actually
super small world like about eight
blocks from the last house that I lived
in before I joined the Navy so I am from
Santa Cruz a super small Beach town on
the coast
and that's where CrossFit was started
but uh Greg had residence in
uh Santa Cruz he had a residence in
Arizona and a residence in San Diego and
he was just on this just Diamond of
death in the car and I had gotten when I
left the East Coast command and come to
the West Coast to be a buds instructor
they were flirting with getting rid of
actually winter hell week they were
trying to increase the throughput of the
program so they did one cycle where
they didn't have a winter hell week and
I checked in they're like we don't
actually have anything for you to do so
see you in a couple months and I'm like
oh [__] it I saw an airplane coming in
to land on my way home and I literally
drove off the took the exit and found
where they land of like this looks like
fun I guess I'll get my pilot's license
didn't do anything with it Greg calls me
one day he's like hey I remember you
saying you had your pilot's license this
drive is just murderous it's like eight
hours each each leg of that triangle
um go get all your ratings get current
again and uh I'm gonna get an airplane
and and so that's what I ended up doing
was oh actually it was kind of that
triangle but a lot a lot of the times
just in the air instead but directly for
Greg and directly for and I flew Dave I
don't know countless times what was the
Glory Days of CrossFit like from the
inside
there were times uh I mean I guess my
metric for that would be how many
seminars they would sell and the
velocity with which they would sell once
they went online I think the peak I ever
saw it is they were doing five different
seminars across the world at probably 50
people at the seminar at a thousand
bucks ahead when I was working for them
and it would they could you could put it
online
and if you had a phone like a Shopify
alert or whatever it would just be like
like the Villa it was unbelievable it's
just he could take a [__] and hundreds
would come out
that's what I did
it was it was the demand
so outstripped the possible Supply it
just was everywhere you know then the
CrossFit Games came about
um so like National TV I still don't
know whether or not that was a good
thing or a bad thing for CrossFit
because it the what they are doing at
the games is actually a really poor
representation of what the actual
CrossFit programming is and it's people
don't they're not even interested in
having that conversation they're just
like that [__] looks crazy I don't want
to do that it's like that's CrossFit
type exercises but that's not really the
programming but it's pretty wild I mean
I was sitting there at the table
uh with three other people when they
negotiated the first Reebok deal the
10-year deal was worth about 150 million
and I ended up managing that with uh a
good friend of mine who was a like uh he
was the lawyer not a lawyer but he was
the lawyer
um it's like a legal backstop but it's
it's crazy man I got to see
fully behind the curtain which
good and also bad many Lessons Learned
yeah yeah man it's uh which actually is
how you and I ended up waking up in the
first place correct yeah we have a a
mutual friend who managed to get himself
into some sort of Quasi litigious
territory uh for
reporting what was pretty I think well
circulated uh information about a bunch
of the guys behind CrossFit yeah uh and
within not long of of talking about this
stuff had been hit with a number of
different
uh threats for litigation I actually
wonder if they would have followed
through you know threading litigation is
one thing following through on it is
another
you know libel all of the things that
you can be threatened with they're
predicated on you saying something
that's not true it's also if everything
is caveated with allegedly yeah or a
story suggests a source close to yeah
you know you can create a lot of degrees
of freedom I don't blame him for the
decision that he made in my experience
um
there are they it's hard to say they
because it's tough at many levels to
separate
CrossFit Inc at least during the time
period that I was working for them
obviously now he's he has moved on it's
under new ownership and I think they
just brought in a new CEO not too long
ago it's hard for me to say where the
separation was between CrossFit and Greg
during the time that I was working for
them but
the legal aspect the threat of uh legal
involvement was 100 there
[Music]
um
yeah I don't know man it's it's strange
that there are an awful lot of stories I
it gives me the impression that a lot of
the guys that run that were a part of
CrossFit from back in the day because
it's a business that remained mostly the
same from a time when the world
relationships within the office between
men and women
um sort of accepted tone uh of how
people in positions of power related to
the people that weren't in a variety of
regards changed so so much yeah you know
from 2004 to 2018
it is Worlds Apart right you have a
complete Reckoning around me too you
have massive changes in terms of what
people expect as as workers as employees
in terms of their rights uh social
movements the Advent of social media and
the expectation of of what is and is not
sort of allowable behavior and um
based on what I know based on My Bro
Science understanding it seems like
there should be a lot of people that ran
CrossFit from back in the day wiping
sweat off their brow for how close the
Sword of Damocles came to [__]
beheading them
ndas are a special thing
some of us chose not to sign them
so was there an offer of yes cash yep
and I told them in no uncertain terms to
go [__] themselves can you say how much
the cash offer was it wasn't that much I
did you know in it was it was like
probably like eight or ten Grand I get
[__]
well you know my relationship with money
as everybody's relationship with money
has changed over time you know the the
best days in the US military the first
and the 15th it's like I got paid
[__] then you get out of the
military like oh [__]
this is a different this is a different
Beast for me very fortunately I had been
double dipping and working on the
weekends
teaching the seminars and I was able to
transition from my military career to
working for CrossFit but he was paying
me more working for CrossFit than I was
making in the military you just you
don't go you can make good money in the
military but to you'll be solidly middle
class right and the amount of money that
he was paying me when I got out of the
military was more than I had ever made
in my life and it was I'm glad that the
experiences that I had
occurred because it was one of the
biggest lessons for me when it came to
money and what it's actually worth and I
got to the point where I just resigned
and went from I was making 150 000 a
year that's what he was paying me to
zero overnight
and totally fine I'm so glad that I did
that it forced me to be more creative it
forced me to find my own path it forced
me to this place where now I'll never
work for somebody else again I'm gonna
work for myself and I figured that out
and you know
to bring it back to the the CrossFit
world
when he offered me eight grand or he did
of course it wasn't through him it was
through the general counsel it's like go
[__] yourself like if I'm gonna go from
150 to zero right now there's no amount
of money in the world that you can ever
pay me that's gonna prevent me from
telling the truth if I want to
and I was honest and he
I did an episode dedicated to my
thoughts around it and I was very Broad
and my thoughts still are the same it's
not actually my story to tell because
people have said to me why didn't you go
more into specifics and the reason I
can't go more into specifics or I'm
unwilling to I should say is that it
bumps up against other people and I
don't want to speak for other people if
they want to speak for themselves or
they want to be heard they are going to
have to do that
and I can talk about the things that I
saw I can talk about the mistakes that I
made I can talk about the things that I
wish I had changed or had done in the
moment and I can try to shed some light
on what had happened in the hopes that
other people can talk
and uh
they did a good job with ndas
it seems that way man it seems that way
you know an awful lot of Stories on the
internet about just what the culture was
like I don't know there was a
I I got into CrossFit in
2016 2017 uh started taking CrossFit
check and and was sold from that and
then
yeah I kind of got to see I think the
sanitization of the anti-marketing
anti-fitness industry movement to
something that some people may call
selling out to Mainstream other people
may say required sanitization uh that
was needed to kind of to kind of clean
it up
um but certainly you know from what I
can see now it's lost its way I think I
don't think that CrossFit has the
cultural hold that it used to the
prevalence of things like high rocks
like high rocks should have never got
off the ground yeah should have never
ever ever got a foothold and the problem
is as you identified earlier I can see
with CrossFit CrossFit tried to be three
things it tried to be a business model
with Affiliates tried to be a
methodology for training and they tried
to be a sport at the highest level and
you are always going to end up
bouncing up against the priorities for
each of those and you saw this when Greg
stepped in and started having 60 year
old people doing bent over rows with
jugs of milk part way through
um covid which I don't disagree it's not
a bad thing like it's supposed to be
Fitness for everybody etc etc
um but that wasn't what people wanted to
see and then the sport of CrossFit came
up against that and that's also not
necessary did the 60 year old people
aren't going to go into your local
CrossFit box and go and do the thing
there so what is it and I think it's
very difficult to try and Wrangle a
beast like that and then there's a talk
of the ESPN deal and then The Buttery
Bros Marsden and and heebs they get let
go on the entire media team gets let go
and then there's like all of this stuff
happens it's a weird move he comes in
one day and fires his entire media team
and it was a it was we know one of the
tranches that they had in the
organization it's uh
[__] there were some
there were some offices
in that building that were barely big
enough for the people in them and not
nearly big enough for their egos
there was like there was in it and I'm
sure that's true of every organization
but a lot of the decisions if you look
at it from an outside perspective like
[__] that's probably purely a punitive
decision that we're making not a great
business decision and no one CrossFit
first caught on I found it in 2005.
it was in comparison to what the rest of
the strength and conditioning world was
doing it was revelatory not that they
created any new movement I can't think
of a single movement that is actually
proprietary to CrossFit but it's how it
was put together
um the programming there certainly was
an essence of the marketing I think you
you know there was a reason that he used
especially 2005 where it's like
what are police doing what are military
doing fire like great marketing uh and
those and those communities did benefit
from it as well so I think that it was
mutually beneficial
but
if you don't evolve
I don't you know eventually you're going
to die and I remember in 2005 like you
could not find a bumper plate in any
24-hour fitness or an Olympic lifting
platform you know any of those things go
into any gym anywhere now and try to
find one that doesn't have a kettlebell
that doesn't have some type of uh object
that you can lift that's something other
than a barbell or an Olympic lifting
station so it it did revolutionize and
change I think a lot of the landscape of
strength and conditioning
but then the company itself kind of
stayed the same and I I would I would
agree with you
struggled to figure out
I think what the messaging of the
company was going to be there's a
a number of phases that you go through
that says the guy that's never built a
multi-million dollar business but I've
got lots of friends that have and it
seems like the naught to 1 million the
one to ten the 10 to 50 the 50 to 100
the 100 to sort of 200 to 200 to half a
bill the build the half Bill to one bill
so on and so forth and at each stage you
need to be allowed prepared to let go of
the things that came along previously
and the problem is that those things
gave you success in the past so you if
you're sufficiently neurotic or
overbearing or a Taskmaster or a tyrant
you're not going to be prepared to let
go of them and
I have a number of friends that have got
billion dollar businesses and what
they've done is been very very good at
just getting out the [__] way and
allowing people that are way more
experienced than them to come in and go
look let me
dissolve everything that you understand
about this and then let me work out how
we turn that into the next iteration of
it but if you're not prepared to let go
of it if you're not prepared to let go
of what it was it can never become what
it's going to be and if you start making
decisions on the whim of whether or not
someone wakes up hungover or grumpy one
day and decides to come in and
you know get rid of people or make
comments or tweet things at inopportune
times you are going to be at the mercy
of and this is currently the same I
learned about how the nuclear football
Works have you do you know the way that
it's like distributed between all of the
different silos no so this is [__]
fascinating so I wanted to find out from
a CIA guy who worked in nuclear the like
nuclear deterrent and nuclear um
Armament division for a while what was
inside of the nuclear football
inside of it you crack this uh sort of
wax thing open and inside that is the
piece of paper the piece of paper's got
the codes on and the president puts the
code in and
I thought
um what happens if there is a I think
it's called a moral objector something
like that in each different Silo and
there's maybe 50 of them around the us
maybe more and in each of them there's
two people and these two people are the
most Junior people in the CIA right yes
they are so Junior it's like and they
work eight hour shifts so eight eight
that's it that's your date sorted in
pairs right like in The Silo correct oh
yep and get this get this right so every
single hour ish it varies but every
single hour an alarm goes off codes come
through they have to type the codes in
both of them both of them turn the keys
both then press the button
every single hour are you sure this
story is true come from a guy that's
part of the CIA
Andrew Bustamante and the people a lot
of people have got a problem with him
but I don't know who that is this story
seems wild though so his argument was
that um
you can have these moral objectures the
story about uh Russia from back in
whenever it was that dude decided I
don't think I think I don't think that
they have sent all of these uh Rockets
over and then they don't and he avoids
you know a disclosure they could
insect dick away from uh nuclear war the
reason that this is stopped is because
it's distributed so uh this comes in
every hour you don't know where you're
firing you don't know if it's a drill or
if it's real which means that everybody
is just in the rhythm of doing it
they're conditioned to press it and
here's the other thing because all of
them are on a network and all of them
are distributed if any one Silo puts in
the codes
it can fire from any of the other silos
so if you've got just one pair out of
let's say it's 50 or 100 that say yes
that do put it in it's go it's gone and
you don't know where it's going and you
don't know if it's real and you don't
know if it's your silo or if you're
pressing a button that goes to another
Silo and you don't know what city it's
aimed at and that just happens pretty
much like within a bit of a play on the
hour every hour and you've got to do
that
I feel like we could get a better system
going
you should go and redesign it that'd be
great I feel like you and me over one
cocktail on a cocktail napkin could
improve this plan I'd be I'm completely
done if the ministry of defense or
whatever the equivalent is over here the
nuclear people I think it's a doe in the
U.S department yeah uh once I learned
the name of the people that make it make
the decisions they can come to me and
I'll help them make the decisions I'm
here for it [__] yeah I'm in I've heard
you say that you don't consider yourself
to be extraordinary consider yourself to
be extremely ordinary correct I actually
heard you say yeah how is it then that
you've managed to achieve some
extraordinary things
uh
you know I think probably the most
exceptional thing that I've ever done in
my life was graduating Seal training
it's the odds are not in your favor
um and at the same and in the same
breath that I will say that I think it's
an exceptional thing
it's not that big of a deal
which is obviously a statement that is
opposed to the one that I previously
made
the seal community
is a community of
extremely Ordinary People they are the
most ordinary run-of-the-mill
could find them at any Street Corner in
any City in any state in the country
they are asked to do occasionally very
exceptional things
um
see the stats on SEAL training and about
75 of people who attempt it don't make
it through
um so I would say that that's probably
something that would be considered
exceptional
but the only thing that I did to
graduate that
was to just keep showing up I mean
there's physical standards don't get me
wrong like you have to physically be
able to do running swimming pull-ups
push-ups all of the requirements I mean
you just take some tests and training
like there's a diving test a dive
physics test
explosive calculations tests all those
things that would be associated with
that the barrier to entry is not high
you actually have to try to trip and
fall
um
but I kept showing up I literally I just
kept showing up
um
and everything else that I've done in my
life has been to a degree if you look at
it what I'm doing right now I what I
what I'm very passionate about and I
enjoy doing especially because my uh the
fact my wife participates in it is Jiu
Jitsu how do you get a black belt in jiu
jitsu
and I have a [__] clue but I'm pretty
sure if you just keep showing up and you
pay attention and you do what the people
are teaching you if you extrapolate that
out over enough period of time you're
gonna eventually one day have a black
belt tied around your waist and people
are going to say that's exceptional and
I think that it is but he didn't just
arrive at that
um I enjoy skydiving
not hard you can make some really
visually appealing
videos and images and you can make
things appear to be more difficult than
they can be but it's just gravity if you
get out of an airplane I'm here to tell
you after 8 500 jumps gravity is going
to work 8500 that's not that many trust
me people who work in the sport who've
been jumping for as long as I have had
have been would have 25
000 30 000 35 000 like true
professionals who work in the sport
minivan skydiving for 24 years at this
point
but it's like if you don't play
parachute you're gonna die if you play a
parachute you're probably going to get
the chance to do it again flying an
airplane
um kind of the same thing like when you
first go and you learn you have to like
there's a knowledge base required and a
practical skill and you incrementally
continue to go and learn more and it's
just
it's not there isn't there is nothing
exceptional about me I graduated high
school with about a 1.8 GPA I played
Sports in high school at what I would
call and I think everybody else would
call a mediocre level
I was on the team wasn't really making
the Highlight Reel obviously mild fears
just competitively average
[Laughter]
just deeply competitively average I'm
not gonna win any aptitude test I'm
certainly not going to win any physical
test
I think the only skill that I probably
refined over time was just I'm not it's
hard to get me to quit I just keep
showing up unless I realize what I'm
doing is utterly meaningless and then
I'll [__] can that thing immediately
uh but that's I mean that's really it
it's I'm not exceptional anything that I
have done is achievable for people
whether or not they want to apply
themselves in the same way that's the
variable
that's it yeah there's a a quote from
James Clay where he says uh consistency
won't guarantee success but if you're
not consistent I guarantee that you
won't be successful I mean
for the 75 percent of people who don't
make it through buds they chose not to
show up one day they made a choice that
terminated that and the people that
graduated they showed up the next day
and it was really hard it's a hard
training program
and you learn how to deal with that and
then you show up the next day and the
next day and the next day I watched a
documentary about the backyard Ultra
race have you seen this
I have watched is that the one of the
crazy ass like long 24-hour one yes okay
well it goes the one that I watched
finished after it was approaching 36
hours I think we're talking about this
four point something miles every hour on
this yes right correct yeah the guy that
created I think it's the Barclay
Marathon um that's the one I'm familiar
with is the parts so it's the same dude
okay crazy guy uh and he didn't like the
fact that people won the marathon he
wanted to create a marathon where the
marathon always won yeah and so he
created this thing and there's a great
documentary it's a tiny YouTube channel
um but if you just search uh backyard
Ultra I think it's in New Zealand or
Australian it's about three weeks old
really really great breakdown of what's
going on uh and this dude who it's his
first ever one he's not a pro or
anything he takes this guy to the
absolute limit and both of them are
going in that's stepping up to the line
at the start and they're FS bumping but
the guy this [__] awesome little
section with the dude that runs it and
he sat on this like
[__] camping chair this crazy Savant of
a a race programmer and he says most
people don't quit during the race most
people quit on the chair
most people don't quit yeah they don't
want to get back off yeah precisely
correct yeah yep they don't quit while
they're while they're running that's the
thing they quit because they sit down
the I would say the number one time at
Buds where people quit is first thing in
the morning
they just they quit at the beginning of
the day before the day even starts it's
uncommon except during hell week
for people to quit mid-evolution that
they just they get to the point where
like you know what I don't even want to
start I'm not even going to try
and
that sucks it uh I've been around a lot
of when I went back as an instructor I
spent a lot of time with the students
who had given up on what they would
Express as their life goals and it's
you're talking with people who are in
probably their lowest emotional state
that they may ever get to in their life
and uh
even in that moment shortly after you
know there's the the you ring a bell
three times and you do have to fill out
some paperwork
but regret regret is the single most
expressed emotion from those people even
in just the moments right after
I spoke to uh Goggins a little while ago
about this and he was talking about the
difference between the person who rings
the bell in the person that doesn't and
he was saying that there are people that
he knows who rang out of buds and
decades later it's still something that
plagues on their mind I've run into them
defining moment of their life just I've
run into them I've run into students who
I was putting through training and as an
instructor you see hundreds of students
so there's no way you're going to
remember the people that uh
so I have not remembered a single one of
the students that has come up to me but
I have run into them and just that
[__] in airports hey instructor stomp
I'm like hey just so you know you can
you can actually call me Andy at this
point because I've been out of the
military for 10 years
and they will say like I wish I had this
happen to me at the Denver Airport
guy pulled me so I was literally head
down walking I you know airpods in just
cruising around guy tapped me on the
shoulder stopped
so you're not gonna remember me you were
working on the hell week shift the shift
that I quit and I think about that every
single day since that happened I'm like
what year was that it's like 2006.
this was last year
I have a friend Alex and he posted
something a couple of days ago that said
the heaviest things in life aren't iron
and gold but unmade decisions and I
think that the weight that people deal
with when it comes to regret and
rumination and what could have been but
when you are you know we were talking
earlier on about differences in degree
not differences of kind and what you
realize is that all of the things that
you choose to do in life
I like that you know whether you choose
to hit the snooze button in the morning
or not whether you choose to eat the
cookie even though you promised yourself
that you weren't going to eat the cookie
so largely those scenarios are just a
value judgment about the story you tell
yourself about what it meant to you
there is no objective reason about why
that particular thing is any different
to hitting snooze in the morning now it
may have caused you to go down a
different sort of Life Path it may have
been a particular
um
inflection point that could have moved
your life in a different direction
but all of us are failing forward on a
minute by minute basis the name of the
person that you forgot the lack of sleep
that you could have done the fact that
you picked your phone up before you saw
sunlight even though you know that you
shouldn't and you know yeah [__]
humor mentions shut up stop talking
negatively about the things that I enjoy
yeah this is my life and you know all of
these different things the different
opportunities that we have to fail or to
succeed are largely a value judgment but
it does make you realize like if you
want to make the most of life you need
to have a degree of resilience and you
need to have a degree of consistency
because without that you're just going
to continue to regress back to the mean
you're going to regress back to the path
of least resistance which is you know
ring the proverbial bowel yeah each
different challenge that you come up
against
I mean it's very common saying how you
do anything is how you do everything it
there's obviously such a huge difference
between hitting the snooze button and
you know ringing the bell
in buds but I I agree with you and I
think
you know resilience is something that
can be built over time and for the
people who are successful who go through
SEAL training and make it out the other
end of it and again it's not like the
most difficult thing that you can do in
your life there are other like [__] go
climb Everest right like you it could be
your thing whatever your thing is the
first thing you have to do is decide
what is important to you and what is not
if you can put for me when I was a very
young man like this is what I want to do
and I started making decisions
and some of them were about I would get
up before going to high school and go
run on a treadmill literally a 24 Hour
Fitness because the information I could
get at the time on buds because the
[__] internet wasn't around was that
you run a lot I'm like okay here I go
I'm gonna go run on the treadmill but
those decisions
you build momentum when you start making
those decisions and they become easier
and for me it was a very magnetizing
pull I and and I don't it's atypical for
people to know what they want to do as
young as I did however that bit me in
the ass when I got out of the military
because I realized I didn't really
thought much past about cultivated
anything else like oh wow I've focused
all my energy on something that I no
longer do anymore so but again that was
a different challenge but
the lens of my life even in high school
was viewed through
is this going to help or hurt me on what
it is that I actually want to do
um
people if they can in my opinion at
least if they can find something that
they have
a goal of that nature whatever it is it
really actually does if you can even
Define a goal like that to pick
something that you care about enough
that it's going to modify your behavior
it makes not hitting the snooze button
that much easier but it starts with what
the [__] do you want to do Define scare
the living [__] out of yourself and pick
a goal that you think you're going to
fail at if you can tell me because I'll
ask people like they'll say well you
know how do I find motivation I don't
know what are you motivated to do oh I
don't really know like how can I
possibly help you find motivation if you
can't even Define for me the end state
where somebody will I want to lose 10
pounds like come on like clearly you're
200 overweight like 10 20 pounds like no
how about you tell yourself you want to
lose 200 and you scare the absolute [__]
out of yourself because you think you're
gonna fail now you've arrived at a goal
that we can talk about
and view your lens or view the world
through that lens of is what I'm doing
helping or hurting that and that's a
tough one because the snooze button is
awesome
I like to hit it sometimes I sleep my
ass off but I didn't when I was younger
because all I wanted to do was be a seal
and you and you have to realize at some
point in time that it's not the world
that's going to make those choices for
you and it's not the world that's going
to decide whether or not you're
successful or not it's your own actions
and how you talk to yourself and how you
frame your goals
and the actions you take upon that that
are going to make the difference and it
it's not easy but it's not exceptional
either
Andy stump ladies and gentlemen where
should people go if they want to keep up
to date with the stuff that you're doing
find out all of your content I wouldn't
follow me if I were you guys
uh
I don't know I'm into some weird [__] um
uh you can find me on social media
channels it's just my name Andy
stumpf212 and then my podcast is called
cleared hot and you can find that on all
the platforms [__] yeah Andy I
appreciate you thank you yep thank you
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace